Hello entonces la moda el arte
pueden salvar al mundo espero que sí en
cualquier caso creo en el poder de los
artistas para ampliar la vida cuando es
demasiado estrecha
una vez que estamos en este espacio todo
se vuelve posible y desde el momento en
que todo se vuelve posible podemos
cambiar el mundo
[Música]
los finalistas de la edición número 37
del Festival Internacional de la moda de
ayer Se tomaron muy en serio las
cuestiones medioambientales en primer
lugar trabajando sobre la base misma de
sus creaciones el material todos ellos
contaron con la ayuda de uno de los
principales socios del festival el
organizador de la feria textil Premier
visión
nos expresamos a través del material
cogemos cortamos nos reapropiamos de las
cosas no importa de donde vengan porque
también tenemos telas que están
manchadas que ya han tenido una vida y
conseguimos hacer con ellas cosas
bastante espectaculares muy deseables
queremos hacer un espectáculo con él
hay una energía en los espectáculos que
es súper emocionante y realmente creo
que es una generación que entiende todos
estos temas pero que realmente Está
avanzando con alegría
una colección hecha de Telas manchadas
Sí pero limpias Por supuesto que fueron
premiadas sin izabala es una joven
diseñadora de moda finlandesa mi
colección se llama lo investible está
fabricado con un 90% de materiales
reciclados con camisetas blancas
manchadas y ropa interior manchada
de hecho Quiero celebrar las tareas de
la vida cotidiana
con una cierta actitud una cierta
sensualidad
todas las manchas
todas incluso las que nos incomodan solo
quería crear algo bello a partir de algo
que generalmente se percibe como feo y
estigmatizado
todo lo que has visto esta mañana tú
como presidente del Jurado cómo te has
sentido
siento que el entusiasmo por el futuro y
el planeta de realmente fuerte está
presente en cada diseñador
Así que cada uno de los participantes
que vimos los 10 son muy diferentes
estéticamente realmente tienen un punto
de vista personal sobre la moda
estéticamente hablando pero por otro
lado todos tienen en común la pregunta
cómo vamos a hacer la moda más adelante
como la producción va a seguir pudriendo
el planeta y cuál es la respuesta y fue
muy agradable ver que ahora está
realmente integrado en la nueva
generación de diseñadores
pero una vez que hayas reciclado todo
con qué vas a trabajar
Creo que vamos a volver a la artesanía
un producto que quizás es un poco más
lento que lleva más tiempo y que también
vivió más tiempo tiene una vida más
larga lo decimos que podamos producir
sino que la respuesta a la moda rápida
está ahí y deberíamos empezar a
utilizarlas
el día se conceden varios premios
iniciados por los socios del festival el
grupo Chanel muy implicado en la
promoción de los
concedió su trofeo al joven espíritu
creativo alemán Valentín Lesnar a otra
chica me gustaría dar la artesanía y en
particular a los objetos hechos a mano
un significado mayor de que tiene hoy en
la sociedad Muchas gracias y también
para trabajar en el propio ritmo de la
industria de la moda Este es el mensaje
que quiero transmitir con mi ropa Qué
edad tiene 25 años
creía que puede cambiar el mundo no no
va a cambiar el mundo
lo que hago puede convertirse en algo
ahora no no sé hago lo que puedo Eso es
todo lo que puedo decir entonces
hay algo especial en su colección
me inspiran sobre todo las culturas
urbanas eso es lo mío
Este modelo está confeccionado a partir
de un tejido italiano blanco liso con
pelo implantado
para la silueta me inspiré en la famosa
chaqueta americana m y onefly
su sueño sería
simplemente hacer ropa y creo que puedo
producirlos de forma responsable y con
sentido
Valentín lessner también recibió el
premio a la colección e corresponsable
en cuanto a la ganadora es finlandesa y
ahora vive en París la colección se basa
en prendas de punto extremadamente
delicadas tejer es mi especialidad
mis piezas están hechas con hilo de
pescar y perlas de vidrio
las perlas se colocan una una durante el
proceso de tejido que hago en casa con
mi máquina
es mucho trabajo
mi superpoder es la paciencia
pero también una idea de contrastes
entre las perlas y los hilos
es casi como si la ropa que he creado
quisiera destruirse a sí misma y sin
embargo viven en perfecta armon Hay
algún mensaje en su colección
Bueno hay que descubrirlo entre líneas
la colección no tiene nombre
no quería darle uno y esa es su fuerza
ganaría
Jenny está llorando de alegría
sin emociones la moda no sería nada
[Música]